President Trump is moving ahead with his
first campaign rally in more than three
months despite health officials calling
it a serious risk for spreading the
corona virus this Saturday's rally in
Tulsa Oklahoma was originally scheduled
for a day earlier on Juneteenth
when many Americans celebrate the end of
slavery all a read is at the White House
Paula what to the president's allies say
about the risk of the corona virus
oh good morning Anthony president Trump
sees these massive campaign events as
his path to re-election and fellow
Republicans are downplaying concerns
that this massive event may help spread
Kovan as Tulsa reports its highest daily
increase in the number of virus cases
and links that spike to large indoor
gatherings the director of the city's
Health Department expressed concern
Saturday about the city's ability to
protect attendees and even to protect
the president but the truth campaign
appears to acknowledge the threat it is
requiring attendees to submit a waiver
agreeing not to sue if they get kovat as
CBS News has learned the rally is
actually now expected to expand across
two different venues after the campaign
received more RSVPs than the original
location could even handle now as for
what the president may talk about during
this event a senior campaign official
tells CBS News they believe that the
defund the police movement and its
support among some Democrats has been a
quote massive gift for that and they
cite polls showing the majority of
voters do not support that movement in
late last week the president said that
he is finalizing an executive order on
police reform and while he says he
rejects the defund the police movement
he is focusing on de-escalation tactics
and even the possibility of having
social workers join officers Tony all
right Paula read for us Paula thank you
very much